Elderly Matthew and Marilla were unmarried siblings.
They lived on their farm, Green Gables, in Prince Edward Island, Canada.
They decided to adopt an orphan boy to help with farm chores.
The orphanage sent them an eleven - year - old girl, Anne Shirley, by mistake.
She was talkative and happy but didn't have very good manners.
Anne's best friend, Diana, got sick one day...
...because Anne accidentally gave her some wine.
Hoping to make Matthew and Marilla proud, Anne studied hard in school.
As a result, she could go to high school...
...and then university as a scholarship student.
But Matthew died of a heart attack and Marilla was going blind.
So Anne returned home to Green Gables,...
...giving up her desire for a four - year university degree.
Hearing of her decision, Anne's childhood rival Gilbert...
...gave up his post as the teacher at Avonlea school.
So Anne could teach there and cared for Marilla.
Though her future path was narrowed, Anne thought cheerfully about her future.